voyage dans le temps au château de
versailles
deux cent quarante ans en arrière 1776
la france sous le règne de louis saez
s'apprête à vivre ses dernières heures
de monarchie elle est la première nation
à reconnaître les états unis d'amérique
la galerie des batailles retrace cette
période avec l'exposition versailles et
l'indépendance américaine
on pense toujours à un engagement
financier
on pense aussi à un engagement
diplomatique fort mais ça a été aussi un
engagement militaire très très
considérable et je ne peux pas
m'empêcher penser que lorsque en 1917
les américains sont arrivés avec cette
lafayette nous voilà il n'y avait pas se
souvenir chez américain de cette dette
de 100 200 français qui avait coulé pour
l'indépendance des états unis
alors pour nous cette exposition c'est
l'occasion de rappeler dans quelles
circonstances cela s'est déroulé quel
était le contexte international
quelle a été l'ampleur du conflit qui
est beaucoup plus immense considérable
que l'on pense puisque ça a été
véritablement un conflit mondial
l'exposition cible le contexte
diplomatique de l'époque
en regroupant des oeuvres venues
d'angleterre de france et des états unis
chaque pays raconte son histoire son
vécu et vient beaucoup d'oeuvres
inédites
il ya beaucoup d'oeuvres inédites et ça
c'est vraiment il ya eu un travail de
recherche de documentation absolument
considérable sur le sujet c'est vraiment
un regard tout à fait nouveau et à ma
connaissance c'est la première
exposition qui sur le sujet veut avoir
cette diversité point de vue une oeuvre
inédite
l'aigle de diamants prêté par l'ordre
des 106 nati l'objet est offert par les
officiers français à washington juste
après la proclamation de l'indépendance
américaine
l'aigle n'est jamais sorti des états
unis sa venue en france est en elle même
un événement l'exposition est à
contempler jusqu'au 2 octobre